what you doing bulk  you don't want to discuss it any further  no  what's up  do you want somebody you want some water  yeah i know i know  i know  yeah  i know mommy loves you  mommy look it's dripping pool you want  to  [Music]  yeah  how about this brush you want to do one  more hair brush oh yeah oh yeah  yes please yes please  you are so spoiled  she insists on doing this like multiple  times a day  she jumps up here and yells because this  is where the brush is  she's like hey mom  hey mom  and then i put that one up here too so  she could  but she never gets up and doesn't the  virus by herself she just  she just does it in conjunction  with this one  yeah  yeah  you have the most brushed hair  and hole in all of kitty dumb poking  you know that  yeah the most brushed hair you know  kitty dumb  because you just get brushed like five  or six times a day yeah  because you won't let mommy not do it  and now right  in that ring  yeah  now she's all  yeah  okay you done sorry